okay so i just want to set a scene for
you so just try to imagine this
you've come home from a hard day maybe
dave's been giving you hell at work
again and you're fighting the urge to
punch his face in or maybe you've been
in school staring at that hot girl who
sits across me from english class again
who the [ __ ] cares
so you open the door until your horror
you see this girl standing over your
dead sister's corpse with a knife in
hand and there's just blood
everywhere like [ __ ] blood on the
carpet blood on the walls not even sham
out and clean up this [ __ ] mess but
most of all it's just that girl is
covered in your sister's blood now this
isn't just any girl this is that girl
you've seen following you home
every night for the past week that
you've never thought too much about
until
now when she gets up turns to you
and you look her in her dead lifeless
eyes while you think to yourself
trembling in anticipation do i have a
boner right now
no mom i'm not going crazy this is
totally a thing
so let's jump right into this what is a
yandere
well remember that crazy obsessive ex
you once stated who started off alright
then began giving off these weird serial
killer vibes anytime you'd start talking
to someone of the opposite sex
well imagine if they did actually become
a serial killer murdering everyone
around you
or even yourself to ensure that no one
else could be with you
that is a yandere the term is derivative
from the japanese words dairy dairy
which means love struck and yandere
which means
[ __ ] be crazy probably it's been a
huge mystery why yandere subsurged in
popularity in recent years
because normally if you see a girl
murdering other people in front of you
in the name of love you'd be like whoa
holy [ __ ] girl that's that's pretty
that's pretty crazy
i mean that's like a jailable offense so
you that you
you you should i i should probably
kill the police because this is some
real [ __ ] up [ __ ] man that's
you just you just [ __ ] killed
somebody
but an anime is like she's so cute best
girl now you may be wondering why anyone
would want a crazy psychotic partner who
has no hesitation in killing you or the
people around you
i mean why seriously why why would you
want that are you a [ __ ] idiot
yes probably definitely i'm definitely
an idiot where was i here at the anime
zone i care about my viewers and i don't
want any of you falling victims to any
yandere so here's everything you need to
know about how to survive a yandere
encounter so the first thing you want to
remember and it's a pretty
easy thing to remember and follow is a
rule number one
yanderes are not crazy they're
misunderstood no no no wait that's
that's not right um what
what wha what was it again oh yeah do
not stick your dick
in crazy rule number two
do not stick your [ __ ] dick in
crazy now properly understanding the
mind of a yandere can actually be quite
hard for normal people so as part of my
research i had to put myself in the mind
of a yandere
think like a yandere act like a yandere
which led me to play yandere simulator
to see if it would give me any clues
day one of yandere simulator and
i find myself doing a lot of uh
research on this topic no conclusive
findings yet
but uh we'll see how it goes so now that
i'm a certified expert on yanderes i can
now guide you through the signs of how
to avoid them
so so this is rule number three every
stranger who starts a conversation with
you
is a yandere i mean come on you're a
loser nerd who spends all his time
inside watching anime the prime prey for
any yandere according to anime so you
gotta be extremely careful when anyone
talks to you
here's an example so you understand say
you're minding your own business on a
crowded bus or something and a girl gets
on and
she points to the seat next to you and
asks excuse me is this seat free
uh-oh code red she wants the d she wants
the d
see she is quite obviously a yandere
trying to stalk you home to kill your
loved ones and anyone you get close to
so now you have several options
you could politely decline her by
eloquently remarking [ __ ] off [ __ ]
your face looks like my mom's clunge
but this is highly unadvised as any
mention of genitalia will probably turn
her on so
i know exactly what you're thinking next
well what if i just [ __ ] myself right
then and there she'll be so repulsed by
it that she won't be attracted to me
anymore and will leave me alone
right wrong yanderes are unconditionally
in love with you so by doing that you've
probably just gotten her into scat
and now you're in even deeper [ __ ] pun
intended no the correct response would
be to get up smack a square in the face
hopefully knocking her out in the
process and then running away as fast as
you can
afterwards you'll then need to migrate
to a different country and change your
name before she has a chance to mentally
recover
day two of yandere simulator i still
don't truly understand what a yandere is
and everyone seems normal enough but
there's this one girl who's just
standing there constantly nothing i do
ever grabs her attention or
anything she's just there always
she's mocking me now all this seems
pretty easy to spot but don't forget
that yanderes aren't always acting crazy
and most of the time they can seem
pretty sweet and innocent before they
snap so there are a few things i can
warn you if someone you know is secretly
a yandere
firstly if their eyes look completely
blank then you know that they're just
one push away from going on a murdering
spree
or they've just taken a [ __ ] ton of lsd
and are tripping balls
and let's not forget their laugh does
someone you know laugh like a mixture
between alvin the chipmunk and the joker
then be careful as they are probably a
yandere rule number four
always be on the lookout for weapons
yanderes will always have some kind of
weapon on hand in case they need to go
on a killing spree but a lot of the
times they are normal household items so
you have to be aware of anything that
could be used to kill
if she has a kitchen knife you have to
question is she just really dedicated to
cooking or does she feel like stabbing
you in the balls
if she has a rope is she planning to
kidnap you or is she just really into
bondage
pencil come on you're just asking to be
stabbed in the eye she has a book
what you don't think she can go jason
bourne on your ass if she has a gun
then you don't need to worry because
yanderes don't use guns she's probably
just an american in that case
i'm yonder a simulator and i can't get
this guy
to realize i exist why won't he notice
me
what do i have to do and lastly rule
five
beware of pink now i don't know where
this came from but pink is the color of
yandere's
even though most yanderes don't have
anything to do with pink now if you're
unacquainted with anime in general you
might be confused as to who the most
famous yanderes are in the medium so
for you here's a starter pack of the top
10 yanderes that everyone needs to know
number ten you know gassai from mirai
nikki
number nine you know gaslight from mirai
nikki number eight
you know gas eye for me right number
seven you know gasoline six you know
number negative twenty-seven from gasa
you know number one
charles manson for mirai nikki and
that's pretty much all the details you
need to know about yanderes but i know
some of you will still be allured to the
charm of someone being completely
devoted for you
even if they do come with a dash of
serial killing so here's the part where
i show a montage of the cutest and most
appealing parts of yonder is to affirm
where people can find them so desirable
so uh
here here we go
yeah that was real cute day five of you
under a simulator
nothing makes sense anymore i can feel
everyone laughing at me
staring they think i'm crazy but they
don't know they don't know the power i
hold the voices in my head told me they
taught me everything
i can do anything i want i just i just
need a chance
and then everyone will see everyone will
see
whoa i'm uh sorry about that guys i
don't know what happened to me
but to get back on track i hope you
learned something today about yanderes
even if i still fully don't understand
how anyone could ever be so crazy to be
like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ah